the parents of one of our Kelly's
live-in girlfriends say she is trapped
and what they call a monstrous situation
only on CBS this morning Alison Angelo
Clary reveal why they are now afraid for
their daughters as riyals life it is
their first interview since the scathing
lifetime documentary surviving our Kelly
azrael Clary met the singer back in 2015
she was 17 at the time her parents claim
that Kelly promised to help launch her
singing career they say they have
learned since then that his real
interest in their words was a little
more sinister I spoke with him yesterday
about how this all started and they say
that just three days after meeting art
Kelly their daughter went to a hotel to
meet him without their permission they
were furious and went knocking on hotel
doors to find her which she said was
this was an audition why would you trust
me y'all would think I would put myself
in a predicament and not call y'all if
something wasn't right
she's saying you're messing up my
chances big break tempers eventually
cooled and the Clarys say they actually
developed a professional relationship
with our Kelly over the next few months
even pitching various business deals all
of which he rejected the Clarys say the
singer had his own proposal let Azrael
join him on his tour full-time he flew
us into Chicago we set with him in his
studio we met with him and he basically
told us you know yeah I'm starting tour
you know basically y'all need to make a
decision as we all had dreams of
becoming a singer according to her
parents who say she dealt with personal
struggles including a suicide attempt
following a bad breakup that was before
she met our Kelly she eventually gave
her parents an ultimatum she says if you
don't allow me to go I will try to take
my own life again or I will run away
mm-hmm I don't want to call her Bluff on
it because I know she just attempted
this previously I'm thinking in my head
she only got three more months she gonna
be 18 so she can do what she wants and
she really carry out this and then now
I'm living with regrets for the rest of
my life from the outside looking in guys
people will still say you're allowing
your seventeen-year-old daughter who at
the time is underage to go with our
Kelly
option is that he preys on underage
girls did that give you any kind of
pause whatsoever
that gave me pause I mean it gave me
awareness but you talk about a young
lady that's raised by two parents so
you're saying you trusted her I didn't
trust him
what I trusted was I raised my child
right I trust my daughter was will be
honest with us and this was strictly I
had music our Kelly had a platform as
big as music can ever give Sam I I
didn't see the label stop supporting and
you told me that you saw him working
with other young women yes last week
Kelly blamed as riyals parents for their
own estrangement what kind of father
what kind of mother will sail they
daughter to a man three months before
Azrael turned 18 the Clary signed a
letter giving their consent for her to
go on Kelly's tour and stay with a woman
named Valerie Denise Peyton who is
Valerie Peyton it ain't Kelly it's not
it's not Robert Kelly but does she work
with our Kelly she posed the work for
the label we found out later on that she
works for our company but at the time
you sign this you thought she was
created with the music from Sony okay so
you thought she would be a chaperone
that's what she was supposed to been
okay mhm and we found out later there
was no truth in it I think it was in
retrospect many of these parents were
too trusting
Michael avenatti is representing the
Clarys he claims our Kelly used his
celebrity status to manipulate the
families and the women if what you're
alleging is true how is he able to get
away with this for this period of time
he surrounded himself with a bunch of
people a bunch of yes men and women that
would provide assurance and comfort to
these parents relating to the fact that
their daughters were going to be safe
that their daughters were going to be
looked after that all of this was legit
that our Kelly could be trusted from
people in the inside some of other
victims that we talked to they all said
that the girls have to prove their
loyalty to him by any means necessary
he's the problem he don't have a
sickness he made a choice and this is
what you guys care
it was not just our Kelly that was doing
this it was it was not only just him and
his handlers and his cohorts and who
whatever you want to call him was my
daughter also our daughter because you
have to understand she was lying and
duping us and pulling the wool over our
house from the beginning when you look
back on it what do you think of the
mistakes that you made do you take any
responsibility we never we never did not
responsibility I feel like I failed my
daughter because I should have saw
different signs
I should have saw saw the change in my
baby girl how do you think this story is
gonna end with your daughter how I want
to see it in I want to see my daughter
leave of course but how do you you
concerned about how it could end or you
I've heard like a suicide pact you know
I know my do sometimes yes I've heard
all kinds of stuff so you know it gives
me chills the difference is our daughter
had experience we're trying to do it see
everybody else can talk but it's nothing
like seeing a father coming in the house
the seen your daughter submerged in
water and you have to pick her up and
try to get it to the hospital so I've
been through that
so why everybody else me take this
lightly and oh they just throwing
something out there it's real life us
Wow would you say they're very
concerning Eureka's piece there was an
anonymous call called in to a hotline
the Chicago Police yesterday after this
interview the Chicago police went to
investigate they found that everybody
was fine and so for now it's okay but
they of course are very worried they say
they've heard that their daughter tried
to leave twice and she was brought back
twice that also concerns them and as for
Valerie painting the woman that we
mentioned we that Larry said they've
never met her and CBS News has not been
able to confirm what her involvement was
with azrael Clary so there's a lot going
on to the story keeps changing
supposedly there's going to be a reunion
with the Clarys and their daughters and
the savages and their daughters this
week we will say it reminds me what this
story really is all about he's a famous
singer an R&B singer but the most
important things is the safety and
security of girls that's the most
important thing and the damage that he
has done in terms of manipul
and abusing allegedly all of these girls
but I think parents also have to take
responsibility to which they are doing
saying they would have made different
decisions well you can see how much pain
they're in yeah as well that's very
clear yeah